[Applaus]
und herren ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht ob sie zu hause das gefeiert
haben aber wir beginnen in diesen tagen
ein jahr groko erster geburtstag
die kleine coco viel älter wirst du
nicht
naja gut darauf deutet zumindest die
stimmung in der groko hin die wir gerade
erleben auch unsere medien achten sie
mal darauf spekulieren ja fast nur noch
über das vorzeitige ende dieser
koalition
ob es im herbst schon im sommer morgen
mittag fragen über fragen geht das noch
gut wie lange hält die koalition noch
steht es wirklich so schlecht um sie bei
meinen sollte eine koalition auf der
kippe vorzeitiges ende der großen
sollten die kanzlerin doch vorzeitig
aufhören vorzeitigen abgang merkel wann
wird angela merkel gehen und wie nah das
ist eine spannende sache befindet auch
das finde ich auch wenn jetzt wo a kk
auch noch außenpolitik macht und dann
makros briefe beantwortet muss sich
angela merkel wahrscheinlich langsam mal
vorbereiten auf das berühmte leben
danach also sich mal in alle richtungen
um gucken einfach um einfach auch
eingespielt zu bekommen ich war vorher
im jobcenter hier in bremerhaven und hab
mich da ein bisschen informiert das ist
nie verkehrt
das ist nie verkehrt meine es gibt so
viele tolle jobs für 64 jährige
physikerin meine damen und herren
ja wir werden gerade live zeuge dieses
fließenden übergangs im wunder von mutti
zur zur großmutter der nation
das ist ein besonderer prozess und auch
wenn ihre groko einiges geschafft hat
muss man ja zugeben kitas pflege
vielmehr kommt da jetzt nicht muss ich
ihnen sagen wegen wahlkampf union nach
rechts spd nach links und natürlich weil
das geld der groko nicht mehr so
sprudelt unser kassenwart der olaf sitzt
jetzt wie gollum auf seinem haushalt und
merkel so norbert küster als nächstes
den etat
doch noch was von flinten dießelberg
weiß es nur noch nicht
ja ja es ist ja so der frau von der
leyen kleiner literatur geht warum mich
von der leyen ist so sauer wegen der
kürzungen die hat schon überlegt zu
putschen aber mit welcher armee
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ja
mir tut es sehr leid steht die arme
jetzt blöd da oder noch im januar hat
sie der nato schriftlich versprochen 1,5
prozent unseres bruttoinlandsprodukts
für rüstung bis 2024
und jetzt geht das dankt herrn scholz in
den nächsten vier jahren auf 1,25 runter
das wird riesig ankommen und trotzdem
bleibt sie immer so rätselhaft fröhlich
ich komme aus niedersachsen und in der
cdu bin ich zu hause
ich habe sieben kinder und einen ehemann
zwei panzer zwei panzer ein hubschrauber
kein u boot und ein kaputtes seit
gestern muss von der leyen auch noch
rede und antwort stehen wissen sie vor
einem untersuchungsausschuss könnte eng
werden wegen ihrer berater geschichte
die so ausufert also kurz gesagt für sie
war es bis jetzt keine schöne groko
allerdings müssen wir sagen war sie
deutlich fleißiger als der kollege
seehofer jetzt mal ernsthaft wo ist der
eigentlich ich mache mir langsam sorgen
also jetzt hat es mal gemerkt man hört
und sieht nichts mehr da hatte doch von
uns ist es ganz neue hier wie heißt das
noch nach ich hab das heimatmuseum der
stadt ministerium richtig wobei projekt
der versprecher
dabei spreche aus dem letzten jahr wobei
wissen sie korrekt wäre heimat mausoleum
beziehungsweise das legendäre horst haus
falkenau so und nach einem jahr groko
also ein jahr später frage ich mich
immer noch was ist das heimat
ministerium was soll das seehofer selber
ist hoch zufrieden auch wenn sein
gesicht was anderes sagt dass heimat
ministerium wir sehr positiv in der
bevölkerung aufgenommen
das heimat ministerium keinen einzigen
gesetzentwurf in den bundestag
eingebracht
wow zwölf monate 0 gesetzentwürfe kein
witz selbst anja karliczek schafft einem
mehr tiefer kannst du nicht sinken
leopard für sein heimatdorf 144 feste
planstellen gekriegt und sie fragen zu
recht was machen diese menschen da ich
kann es ihnen erklären also bei so einem
heimat ministerium brauchst du an der
spitze natürlich erstmal ein chef der
den ganzen tag keine einzige idee hat
keine dann gibt es eine abteilung mit 30
beamten die sämtliche ideen wie seehofer
nicht hat nicht umsetzen und ganz
wichtig auch nicht aufschreiben
ja ich meine da passieren schon sachen
manchmal kommt eine taube ans fenster
dann freuen sich alle nebenan prüfen
zehn juristen ob seehofers ideen
rechtlich in ordnung gewesen wären wenn
er welche gehabt hätte und wenn sie
jetzt fragen was ist mit den restlichen
die gucken natürlich heimatfilme und
dabei weißwürste das ist ja klar
weil das nicht
ja
man könnte es auch so sagen seehofer
lebt ganz entspannt von horst vierter
jetzt aber die überraschend gute
nachricht ein großprojekt scheint die
zerstrittene woco noch ernsthaft
anzugehen in diesen tagen ein echtes
großprojekt bitte grundrente die kommt
nicht mehr das können sie vergessen die
groko wir jetzt die commerzbank mit der
deutschen bank zwangsverheiraten quasi
zusammennähen dabei gilt letztere
manchen jetzt schon als die
gefährlichste bank der welt
die deutsche beide haben immer noch ja
beide haben immer noch ganz schwer zu
kauen an ihrer letzten fusion wirklich
was soll der quatsch wenn sich zwei
fußkranke zusammentun wird daraus noch
lange kein dream team aus zwei kranken
macht man kein champion zwei lage so
heißt es hier in frankfurt die werden
nicht automatisch zu einem
marathonläufer zwei kranke truthähne
ergeben keinen adler ja so sagt man vier
kranke truthähne ergeben einen
kastrierten beseitigt und das ganze
verdanken wir olaf scholz olaf scholz
will wohl unbedingt einen nationalen
banken champion schaffen hat er gesagt
warum auch immer näher und dafür werden
dann wahrscheinlich bei beiden banken
zehntausende arbeitsplätze rasiert die
aktienkurse und zwar von deutscher und
commerzbank sind nach der meldung direkt
hochgegangen alleine das beweist dass
hier was furchtbar schief läuft wir
schalten wir live an die frankfurter
börse zu dr holger stockhaus er leitet
bei den fusionsgesprächen die
sondierungsgruppe der deutschen bank dr
stocker aus hauptsächlich soll doch hier
ihre bahn gerettet werden oder ich meine
die aktie hat allein im letzten jahr 50
prozent verloren ja alles relative value
unsere aktie steht vielleicht gerade
nicht so doll da aber was soll ich sagen
kollege vom vom bayer-konzern grüße
schöner alter ist den kurs ab geraucht
nachdem glyphosat prozess diese woche
ist der wahnsinn
auch wenn er geht auch wieder für sowas
auf dem parkplatz des sind probleme
sicher so eine banken fusion findet der
bürger nico dabei da bitte ich auch
einfach mal um pc empathie hier der
commerzbank-chef unser thema und dass
der gesamten branche ist
wir verdienen einfach nicht genug geld
[Applaus]
[Musik]
viel zu wenig geld
entschuldigung das geht nicht auch
ziemlich na ja auch meine deutsche bank
was die in letzter zeit durchmachen
musste zins manipulation betrug mit
klimazertifikaten geldwäsche in russland
den dänemark rom hypotheken-deals ja
aber da habt ihr doch alles gemacht
ach wissen sie der welt das ist wieder
so deutsch
wer ist schuld stadt einmal
unbürokratisch zu helfen
wir müssen jetzt fusionieren fertig aber
jesus nicht mal keine bank darf jemals
wieder so groß werden dass sie in die
position kommt regierung zu erpressen
will wer denn dem pult steht erzählt das
ist einmal das thema das keine bank so
groß werden darf dass sie in eine
position kommen kann und regierungen
erpressen kann ja 2009 da war die frau
fast noch ein kind
ihre einzige erfahrung in der
finanzbranche waren 100 mark
begrüßungsgeld
mittlerweile steckt sie tief drin im
thema und sagt zur fusion absolute
private entscheidung mit all den
herausforderungen chancen und risiken
und das müssen und können nur die
akteure selbst bewerten so das können
nur mehr selbst bewerten ob nähte
regierung erpressen wolle
too big to fail das ist lächerlich es
gibt ja auch keine tour guide to [ __ ]
was sagt eigentlich die commerzbank dazu
wird die jetzt geopfert um euch zu
retten dahin also die freuen sich riesig
das ist ja auch eine chance für die
adler kommt ja der commerzbank kollege
so den werde ich jetzt mal nach allen
regeln der kunst schön durch fusionieren
viel spaß holger stockhaus meine damen
und herren
[Applaus]